Schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag.
Paul, das ist mein Name.
Ich möchte auf diese Station als ...
Ich bin auf diese Station als Stänzentätich
und würde mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind zusammen mit einverstanden?
Ja, da heißt Aufnahmegespräch, denn dass ich dann auch hier bleiben muss?
Nein, noch nicht.
Oder Anamnesegespräch hören?
Ja, okay.
Gut, niederklar können wir zusammensprechen.
Okay.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden sprechen,
möchte ich Ihre persönlichen Daten erfahren.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Kerstin Hoffmann.
Okay.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist K-E-R-S-T-I-N.
Kerstin.
Kerstin, das ist ein Frauenname, ne?
Hoffmann H-O-Doppel-F.
M-A-N.
M-A-Doppel-N.
Doppel-N.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Hoffmann?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8. März, 84.
Okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
70 Kilo ungefähr.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Okay.
Frau Hoffmann, was für was für Beschwerden Sie haben?
Wie viele Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Im Moment geht es mir schon wieder gut.
Aber ich habe vor Kurzen etwas ganz Merkwürdiges erlebt.
Deswegen ist mein Mann auch mit mir mitgekommen.
Weil das wirklich eine ganz komische Situation war.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht so 2, 3 Stunden her.
Ich musste mit einmal Zucken an den Armen und an den Beinen.
Ich habe mich mit einem starken Kopfschmerzen gesehen.
Ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, dass ich Herzrasen habe.
Dann war das mit diesem komischen Gezappel vorbei.
Danach war es mir schlecht.
Ich habe mich wirklich übel gefühlt.
Ich fühle mich sehr schlecht.
Ich habe mich sehr schlecht gefühlt.
Ich habe mich wirklich übel gefühlt.
Ich fühle mich so müde und erschöpft.
Diese Beschwerden sind vor 2 oder 3 Stunden eingefangen.
Ja, vor ungefähr 3 Stunden ist das hier zu Ende.
Sie haben gerade erwähnt, Ihre Armen und Beine.
Sie haben sich etwas komisch gemalt.
Ja, ich konnte sie nicht kontrollieren.
Sie haben so gezappelt und gezuckt.
Hatten Sie früher schon einmal so etwas?
Nein, ich habe so etwas überhaupt noch nie erlebt.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, ich muss unbedingt hierher kommen.
Sie haben gut gemalt.
Ich möchte über Kopfschmerzen fragen.
Wo genau ist der Kopfschmerzen?
Oh, jetzt sind sie ja wieder ziemlich weg.
Aber die waren, glaube ich, auch auf beiden Seiten hier oben.
Wie lange dauert die Beschwerden?
Ich kann das nicht sagen.
Das war wahrscheinlich nicht lange,
wahrscheinlich nur wenige Minuten.
Aber die Schmerzen, das war vielleicht so eine halbe Stunde vorher.
Frau Hofmann,
wenn diese Beschwerden vorbei waren,
ist Ihnen übel.
Aber müssten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, übergeben muss ich mich nicht.
Ich fühle mich total schlapp und auch wirklich übel.
Haben Sie in dieser Zeit bewusst sein verloren?
Ich glaube nicht.
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist vielleicht noch mal mein Mann,
der im Wartezimmer war.
Oder sind Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden gestützt?
Nein, im Gefallen bin ich nicht.
Nein, ich habe mich dann hingesetzt,
als ich das gemerkt habe,
dass ich das alles nicht mehr kontrollieren konnte.
Und dadurch ist nichts passiert.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für diese Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel viele Stress oder Trauriernachricht?
Ja, ich bin seit ein paar Tagen
ein bisschen kribbelig und unruhig.
Gestern Abend haben wir bei der Arbeit
eine große Party gehabt.
Vielleicht habe ich ein bisschen viel Alkohol getrunken.
Ich hatte schon gut was zu trinken.
Deswegen habe ich erst gedacht,
dass das die Kopfschmerzen davon kommen.
Aber als das losging, war mir das sehr unheimlich.
Ja, verstehe.
Aber diese Beschwerde sind erst mal aufgetreten.
Das hatte ich vorher noch nie.
Ja, verstehe.
Frau Hoffmann, haben Sie Fieber oder Stülfrost?
Nein, ich habe mich jetzt nicht gemessen.
Aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Und die Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht.
Oder leiden Sie unter Kalten-Schweiz oder nach Schweiz?
Normalerweise nicht.
So was habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie in der Lästerzeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Hier habe ich mich. Das ist ziemlich stabil.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist es eigentlich ganz gut.
Super.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Stuhlgang
oder Ihre Wasserlassen etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Ja, also ich habe schon lange ein bisschen Darmprobleme.
Der Hausarzt hat mal gesagt, das wäre ein Reizdarm.
Ich muss also mit dem Essen eigentlich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Und wenn ich zu viel fettiges Zeug esse
oder schwerverdauliche Sachen,
dann habe ich schon mal Probleme mit der Verdauung.
Aber im Normalfall eigentlich nicht.
Meinen Sie Verstopfung, oder?
Nein, eher das Gegenteil.
Eher, dass ich Durchfall habe.
Dass ich dann etwas, was ich an einem Tag,
viermal auf die Toilette muss.
Wie lange seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Bestimmt schon zehn Jahre.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen?
Nein, nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, also war mir vorhin schwindelig.
Richtig schwindelig war mir eigentlich nicht.
Ich hatte nur so dieses Kontrollverlust.
Nein, ich schwindelig war mir nicht.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Nicht so wirklich gut.
Ich schlafe ein bisschen unruhig.
Und ruhig gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schlafstörungen?
Ja, vielleicht wenn ich mal ein bisschen Stress bei der Arbeit habe,
wenn es da mal Probleme gibt oder so,
dann kann man nicht so gut einschlafen.
Oder irgendwie so Kleinigkeiten wahrscheinlich.
Aber das ist das zu leicht, wenn ich dann lange,
da schon manchmal, wenn ich Nachrichten gesehen habe
und die regen mich auf,
dass ich dann nachts nicht gut schlafen kann.
Okay.
Frau Hofmann, ich möchte zurück in Ihre Beschwerden kommen.
Sie haben etwas gesagt.
Sie leiden unter Herzrasen oder Lichtblitzen.
Diese alle Beschwerden sind gleichzeitig aufgezelt.
Ja, das war also, bevor das anfing mit der Zappelei,
habe ich mir einmal gemerkt,
wahnsinnige Kopfschmerzen, das Herzklopf und diese Lichtblitze.
Das war so ein bisschen unheimlich.
Und dann als mein Mann dann gesagt hat,
was ist denn mit dir los?
Ich fing das halt mit den komischen Zuckungen an.
Das ging wahrscheinlich gar nicht so lange.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe mich gar nicht getraut.
Ich habe irgendwie gedacht,
es hängt vielleicht mit dem Alkohol von gestern Abend zusammen.
Okay, Frau Hofmann.
Ich möchte über Vorgeschichte fragen.
Das ist Ihnen bekannt?
Zuckerkrankheit oder neurologische Probleme?
Was ich habe, ist diese Reizgarmengeschichte.
Das ist, da war ich beim Bein,
Halsnase, Ohrenarzt.
Ich habe so ein bisschen Probleme mit der Sprache.
Ich habe so Stimmbannknochen.
Ich bin nicht so heiser.
Ich habe noch eine Geschichte,
dass ich hinter den Ohren so eine Haut selber auftrage.
Wenn das zu deutsch schubig wird.
Die Hautverwerbung,
Hinten der Ohr,
seit wann haben Sie?
Das habe ich schon lange.
Da kommt man erstmal nicht drauf.
Ich habe es in den Ohren gejuckt.
Dann hatte ich diese Schuppen.
Das ist bestimmt schon zehn Jahre auch.
Gibt es noch andere Erklärmkungen?
Das ist eigentlich alles.
Können Sie bitte mehr erklären?
Manchmal machen mich heiser.
Ich habe nicht viel gegen tun.
Dann muss ich manchmal viel husten.
Wenn das unangenehm ist,
wenn ich merke, dass ich extrem heiser werde,
dann muss ich diese Lutzstabletten nehmen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlucken?
Nein.
Das ist mehr dieses Heiserheitsproblem.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, regelmäßig.
Nicht mehr bei Bedarf.
Gegen diese hautgeschichte hinter den Ohren.
Da habe ich eine Salve, die heißt Lügeal.
Lügeal Kopfsalve.
Wenn ich dann voll schuppig werde,
dann streiche ich mir das hinter die Ohren.
Wenn es mit dem Darmproblem gibt, dann nehme ich Immudium.
Für diese Heiserkeitgeschichte,
da habe ich Neo-Angene.
Das ist eine Lutzstablette.
Neo-Angene.
Frau Hofmann, sind Sie früher schon einmal operiert worden?
Da muss ich mal zurück.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich jemanden eine Operation hatte.
Keine Operation?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen allergisch bekannt?
Ja, ich darf essen und keine Muscheln.
Das vertrage ich nicht.
Fisch und?
Ich habe mich verstanden.
Muscheln, du Meeresfrüchte.
Ein bisschen reagiere ich auch auf Hausstaub.
Da muss ich niesen und kriege so rote Augen.
Insofern muss ich bei mir immer gut alles sauber machen.
Ich muss alles sauber halten, Staubsaugen und Lüften.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Frau Hofmann, lauchen Sie?
Ja, das mache ich schon seit ich 18 bin.
Ich brauche ziemlich regelmäßig, aber nicht so viel.
Ich brauche eine halbe Packung am Tag.
Aber seit Sie 18 Jahre alt war?
Ja, auch.
Aber es ist schon lange.
Ja, 20 Jahre ist das her.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich habe es gerade erzählt.
Gestern Abend ein bisschen viel.
Aber ich trinke nicht jeden Abend.
Wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt, trinken wir schon was.
Manchmal ein bisschen zu viel.
Was trinken Sie jeden Tag?
Jeden Abend trinke ich nicht.
Aber hin und wieder ein Bier oder ein Glas Wein.
Wenn man in Gesellschaft ist,
vielleicht ein, zwei Gläser sägt.
Wenn es gut schmeckt, ein Cocktail.
Alles was gut schmeckt.
Ja, verstanden.
Sie meinen Geld trinken?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Nein, hin und wieder gibt es mal ein Joint, aber nicht oft.
Wie oft?
Einmal im Monat oder so.
Frau Hofmann,
haben Sie regelmäßig Periode?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie Pille?
Nein, die habe ich nicht vertragen. Ich habe eine Spirale.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig beim Frauenarzt?
Ja, klar. Da gehe ich regelmäßig hin.
Frau Hofmann, könnte es sein, dass sie schwanger wäre?
Nein, eigentlich kann das nicht sein.
Frau Hofmann, was sind Sie von der Ruh?
Ja, ich bin selbstständig. Ich habe einen Kopischop.
Haben Sie Probleme bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Nein, eigentlich.
Bei der Arbeit ist natürlich stressig.
Es gibt immer wieder Konkurrenz.
Es muss manchmal schnell gehen.
Die Kunden sind unfreundlich.
Da hat man schon mal Stress.
Normalerweise ist das ganz gut.
Viele Menschen benutzen die Kopie.
Es muss immer schnell gehen, wenn die zu uns kommen.
Die wollen alle nicht warten.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Ich habe eine Frau, die ich nicht verheiratet habe.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, einen Sohn habe ich.
Sind Sie gesund?
Mein Sohn ist gesund.
Ja, mein Sohn ist gesund.
Wohnen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, klar. Wir wohnen zusammen.
Frau Hofmann, ist in Ihrer Familie oder in Ihren Hältern
eine chronische Erkrankung bekannt?
Die chronischen Erkrankungen haben sie nicht.
Ihr Vater oder Ihre Mutter?
Bei meinem Vater hatte ich jetzt neulich mal
eine Hornhaut-Operation.
Da war eine Entzündung im Auge.
Aber das ist keine chronische Erkrankung.
Meine Mutter hatte tatsächlich
üble Schmerzen.
Die hatte sich das Handgelenk gebrochen, das Linke.
Die Erzame ist ein Morbus-Sudeck.
Die hat permanent starke Schmerzen.
Und wird damit nicht richtig fertig.
Das ist ein bisschen doof, die Situation.
Aber auch das ist keine chronische Erkrankung.
Das ist eine sehr große Erkrankung.
Das ist ja keine chronische Erkrankung.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Okay, Frau Hofmann.
Meinerseits habe ich wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Aber haben Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe so viel erzählt, was heute alles passiert ist.
Ich kann mich auch nicht so gut konzentrieren.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe Ihnen wirklich alles genau geschildert.
Ich möchte Ihnen natürlich ganz gerne wissen,
wie kann denn so etwas kommen
und muss ich befürchten, dass so etwas wieder kommt?
Ja, ich werde mich befürchten.
Ich werde mich befürchten, dass es so etwas kommt.
Ich werde mich befürchten, dass sich0
Nach dem Ergebnis besprechen wir nochmal.
Okay, ja.
Wie lange dauert denn die Untersuchung?
Ich untersuche so schnell wie möglich.
Das dauert nicht so lange.
Machen Sie keine Sorge.
Okay, dann kann mein Mann warten, ne?
Ja, nehmen Sie im wartesten Platz.
Ich werde Untersuchungsschrauchen vorbereiten.
Dann Sie an aufrufen.
Wunderbar, alles klar.
Dann gehe ich jetzt und warte auf Sie.
Danke.
Danke, gerne.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Hat der eine Ehreikollegen bei der Besprächung gestern Abend
ähnlich beschwerden wie Sie?
Ah, das ist eine interessante Frage.
Ich habe von niemandem gehört.
Von den Kollegen bei der Party.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, dass irgendjemand anderes auch krank ist.
Aber es ist ein interessanter Aspekt.
Waren Sie in der Serzite im Krankenhaus?
Wann waren Sie das letzte Mal hier bei Ihnen?
Eine Blutunterricht ok.
Das ist schon lange her.
Sie haben gesagt, Migräne, eine Diagnose gestartet.
Und Sie haben Medikamente eingenommen.
Irgendwärsch eine Migräne-Attack aufgetreten.
Nein.
Migräne habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, der Matitis hinter dem Ohr.
Also Hautveränderung hinter dem Ohr.
Reizdarm.
Und die Stimmbandknötchen.
Aber Migräne habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich habe erst den.
Ich wüsste nicht, wann ich das ...
Ich habe nur gesagt, die Kopfschmerzen waren hier oben.
Vielleicht haben Sie da die Migräne rausgeschlossen.
Haben Sie Ihre Blutdruck einmal gemessen?
Nein, ich habe kein Blutdruckmessgerät zu Hause.
Normalerweise habe ich keinen hohen Blutdruck.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Unterwaschen nass geworden sind?
Ob ich eingenässt habe, ja.
Nein, ist zum Glück nicht passiert.
Na gut.
Na dann können wir als Alsats-Gespräch anfangen?
Ja, können wir anfangen.
Gut, wir anfangen.
Bitte schön.
Guten Abend, Frau Obersten.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Diese Patientin heißt Kerstin Hofmann.
Sie ist 58,86 kg geboren.
Sie ist 60 kg schwer und 1,68 m groß.
Die 38-jährige Patientin stellte sich bei uns wegen starker Kopfschmerzen,
Lichtblitzen und Tahika, die vor diese Beschwerden haben
vor 3 Minuten.
Die Patientin berichtete, dass sie auch ihre Arm und Beine sittern.
Die Patientin gab auch Wärme und dort viel Alkohol getrunken habe.
Die Bekleidzentrum sind Tahikadi und Schlafstörungen.
Auch Stuhlgangprobleme, die weitere vegetative Anäse sind unauffällig.
Die Patientin an Vorerkrankungen sind folgende Beschwerden oder folgende Erkrankungen bekannt.
Sie reißt seit schon 10 Jahren und stimmband Knöchen.
Sie leidete sie unter Halsigkeit und Husten.
Auch Dalmatitis, hinten auch Boar.
Die Patientin nimmt bei Bedarf eine Salve, Nougal Salve für den Matitis,
Immudium für Reisdarm Beschwerden und Neuangin für Halsigkeitprobleme ein.
Sie ist keine Operation bekannt.
Die Patientin hat Unfertigkeiten mit Fisch und Muschel.
Sie ist vorstellend geimpft.
Die Patientin ruft seit 20 Jahren eine halbe Packung.
Das entspricht 10 Packungen.
Sie trinkt die Alkohol, außer nur im Party oder im Treffen mit Freunden.
Die Patientin konsumiert einmal pro Monat Jund.
Die Patientin berichtete, dass sie regelmäßige Periode haben.
Sie besuchte regelmäßig bei Frauenarzt.
In der Familienanamnese gibt es keine chronische Erkrankungen in ihrer Familie.
Sie arbeitet selbstständig beim Kopischop.
Sie ist verheiratet und sie hat einen gesunden Sohn.
Sie ist mit ihrer Familie.
Nach einer anaesthetischen Angabe gehe ich von epileptischen Attacke aus.
Aber die Diagnostik könnte auch Alkohol in Toxikation sein.
Sie ist mit einer Diagnostik in Toxikation.
Ich habe noch zwei andere Sachen.
Es gibt schon viele Parallelen zur Migräne.
Sie ist mit einer Diagnose in Toxikation.
Ich werde erst einmal körperlich untersucht.
Ich werde mit einer Diagnose in Toxikation.
Ich nehme Blut ab.
Ich möchte In Toxikation ausschließen.
Ich werde mit einer Diagnose in Leberwerte.
Die Elektrolyte sind natürlich auch interessant.
Was machen Sie weiter?
Ich würde eine CT-Shade für die Patienten durchführen.
Wenn ich alle Diagnose ausgeschlossen habe,
dann möchte ich EG bestimmen.
Was ist das Problem bei EG?
Die Beschwerden sind vorbei.
Ich habe mich nicht informiert, dass es im EG nur etwas ist.
Ich habe mich nicht informiert, dass es unaufwärtig ist.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Ich möchte nicht sofort die Epilezidische Medikamente anfangen.
Ich empfehle die Patientin, wenn die Patient noch mal diese Beschwerden haben,
die sofort zum Krankenhaus gehen, dann bestimmen und Medikamente anfangen.
Was gibt es noch für Anweisungen an die Patientin?
Die Patientin hat auch gesagt, dass sie etwas gefühlt haben,
sie hat erst mal Kopfschmerzen, dann die andere Beschwerden angefangen.
Deswegen ist die Patientin bemerkbar für die Epilezidische Attacke.
Sie ist als Vorzeichen wertvoll.
Wenn Sie 40 Anzeichen empfehle, ich zu sitzen.
Was geben Sie denn, was die Lebensführung angeht?
Damit der nächste Epileptische Anfall nicht in zwei Wochen kommt.
Worauf muss die verzichten?
Sie sollte eine stressige Situation versichten.
Sie sollte nicht so viel Alkohol trinken und trocken.
Genau, nicht so viel. Die soll absolut abstinent leben.
Sie soll Alkohol, Nikotin und Drogenkarrenz einhalten.
Sie soll darauf achten, dass sie genug schläft.
Ja, stimmt.
Sie soll nicht Auto fahren.
Sie soll wieder eine Attacke bekommen, dass sie etwas nicht am Lenkrab bekommt.
Ich habe zumindest hier als Hinweis stehen, dass sie für die nächsten Monate auf alles verzichten sollte.
Das waren von mir aus die Sachen.
Dann untersuchen Sie mal die Patientin.
Ich bin gespannt, was Sie bei der Zitieruntersuchung rausbekommen.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Nehmen Sie die Patientin stationär auf oder geht die nachher nach Hause?
Wenn ich alle Untersuchungen erledigt habe, kann dieser Patient zu Hause gehen.
Gut, mit den Verhaltensregeln.
Wer möchte etwas sagen dazu?
Das ist ein interessantes Frage.
Wir sind sprachlich.
Wir sind unexakt in den Aufgefahren.
Die Patientin ist am 8.03.1984 geboren.
Sie haben die Obereinheit auf der Zitieruntersuchung.
Ich habe Probleme mit Falen.
Die Klassiker sind 14, 15, 16 und 40, 50, 60.
Das geht bei ganz vielen Schwerdreche.
Was Sie nicht richtig geschildert haben, der Oberärztin,
ist die Reihenfolge der Symptome.
Sie hat diese Zukunft an Armen und Beinen geschrieben.
Eine halbe Stunde vorher fing das mit den Kopfschmerzen
und mit den Lichtblitzen an.
Sie hat diese Phase über eine halbe Stunde gedauert.
Die Symptome waren eine halbe Stunde vorher.
Danach war sie schlapp und erschöpft und K.O.
Ich habe mich gefragt, ob ich ein Genest habe.
Das wäre ein Klassiker bei dem epileptischen Einfall.
Ich habe mich einmal gesagt, dass es ein bisschen türkisch im Deutschen ist.
Wenn der Anfall vorbei ist, dann passiert das und das.
Sie sprechen aber über die Vergangenheit.
Wenn ich das Buch leiste, schicke ich es dir nach 3 Monaten zurück.
Wenn einer etwas macht, mache ich etwas anderes.
Wenn die Ferien vorbei sind, kommen alle Schüler wieder zum Unterricht.
Wenn ich retrospektiv sage, dann muss ich sagen, als der Anfall vorbei war,
fühlte sich die Patientin schlapp und müde.
Das sind natürlich Winzigkeiten, aber es sind viele Winzigkeiten.
Malerweise benutze ich alles oder wenn die Pferanzierung ist.
Die vegetative Anamnese sind sonst unhauffällig.
Die Anamnese sind singular.
Sie haben das Bewusstsein nicht verloren.
Ich habe keine Medikamente genommen.
Ich habe keine Verdauerstörung.
Dann bezieht sich die Verneinung auf das Nomen.
Hier geht es darum, habe ich das Bewusstsein verloren, habe ich nicht.
Sie haben das Bewusstsein nicht verloren.
Werben verneinen wir mit Nicht, Nomen verneinen wir mit Kein.
Sprachlich nur. Das sind keine illhaltlichen Sachen, sondern nur sprachliche Sachen.
Und Leiden ist ein leiden ist ein unregelmäßiges Verb.
Sie litt an, nicht sie leidete an.
Die unregelmäßigen Verben sind zugegeben, schwierig.
Deswegen benutze ich das Perfekt.
Das war viel sprachlicher Kleinkram.
Sie waren sehr nett zu der Patientin.
Bis auf diese Geschichte, dass sie diese Reihenfolge nicht so richtig gemacht haben,
war die Schilderung als Arztgespräch auch okay.
Es waren zu viele Fehler drin, in dem sie nicht richtig wiedergegeben haben.
Das würden ihnen ihre Prüfer im Zweifelsfall übernehmen.
Wenn sie sagen, dass die Kopfschmerzen nur ganz kurz gedauert haben,
nein, sie haben über 30 Minuten gedauert.
Das muss man zeitlich im Zweifelsfall nachfragen.
Wenn sie nicht sicher sind, dann fragen sie noch mal nach.
Das ist die Geschichte.
Sie hat Schlafstörung beschrieben.
Gehört der Reizdarm jetzt zur vegetativen Anamnese oder zu den Vorerkrankungen?
Das kann man wahrscheinlich auch drüber streiten.
Ich habe es jetzt, als Sie gefragt haben,
haben Sie Probleme mit der Verdauung?
Ich habe schon lange ein Reizdarm.
Bei einem von beiden muss man es sicherlich erwähnen.
Aber die Verdauungsstörungen standen ja jetzt nicht in Zusammenhang mit diesem Event.
Sondern waren Olaf hängig davon.
Ich wundere mich, dass dieser Patient aus der Reizdarm
zwei Verständeprobleme, Heiserkeit und Dematitis während des Geschepress
immer auf diese Beschwerden abhängig ist.
Es hat gar nichts damit zu tun, offensichtlich.
Sondern das führt den Fall nur auf,
gibt den Anlass nach irgendwelchen anderen Sachen zu fragen.
Wie heißt eine Stimmstörung?
Da muss man erst mal wissen, dysphonie.
Stammt hier irgendwo.
Genau so wie diese Lichtblitze.
Wissen Sie, wie das heißt?
Das heißt Fotopsy.
Die hat also Lichtwahrnehmungsstörungen.
Darauf kommt es ja auch immer den Prüfer ein bisschen an,
die haben ja auch Terminologien im Arztgespräch.
So weit ich weiß, versuchte ich zu erwähnen, aber Lichtblitze wusste ich nicht.
Und, ich habe noch was unterkringelt.
Sie haben bei den Allergien die Meeresfrüchte genannt,
aber die Hausstaubmüben, die sind jetzt in Unterschlagen.
Haben Sie nicht erzählt?
Ja, genau.
Das war viel Maulerei jetzt.
Ich hoffe, Sie nehmen mir das nicht übel.
Aber ich habe heute Abend gut aufgepasst.
Wenn ich nichts sage, haben Sie ja auch nichts davon.
Dann haben Sie nachher Ärger in der Prüfung und sagen,
wieso hat die nie was gesagt?
Das ist auch blöd.
Im Dauß werde nützlich Ihre Finger weg.
Danke.